bonsoir et bienvenue ravi de vous
retrouver en direct sur LCP notre grand
témoin ce soir à le sens du timing c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire bonsoir Patrice
duamel et merci infiniment d'être là
vous êtes éditorialiste politique
journaliste mémoire en peu de la 5e
République et ancien directeur général
de France Télévision vous publiez
aujourd'hui même un ouvrage je le disais
qui tombe à pque le chat et le renard
président et premier ministre deux ou
trois choses que je sais deux aux
éditions de l'Observatoire on va y
revenir dans la longueur le passé le
présent aussi vous nous direz qui du
chat et du renard est Gabriel Attal ou
Emmanuel Macron tout à l'heure dans la
deuxème partie notre grand débat ce soir
le président lance la bataille contre le
rassemblement national on va revenir
avec quatre députés sur la conférence de
presse présidentielle d'hier à l'Élysée
uniforme à l'école marseillaise or ordre
autorité bon sens et classe moyenne
assiste-t-on à un tournant conservateur
peut-on faire baisser le RN en allant
sur son terrain et le Parlement dans
tout ça nous en débattons dans un
instant sur ce plateau enfin nos
affranchis ce soir regard de profs sur
l'uniforme notamment après les annonces
présidentielles ce sera avec Yanis roder
et puis qui pour mener la bataille
européenne on verra ça avec l'Européen
et l'ami Richard verli enfin Bourbon
Express ce soir signé Stéphanie des
piierres voilà pour le menu on y va
Patrice duamel ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
parti et si c'était mieux avant le chef
de l'État aurait-il de nouveaux accents
conservateurs pour lutter contre ce
qu'ilaelle le sentiment de dépossession
famille école ordre progrress travail
mérite pour que la France reste la
France je cite le Président on va
revenir sur la conférence de presse
d'Emmanuel Macron qui veut redonner je
cite des repères face à la montée du RN
al leur retour au macronisme des
origines ou virage à droite assumer
christopherisberg bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous député renaissance des
Français établis en Amérique du Nord
porte-parole du groupe Renaissance à
l'Assemblée ce soir vous débattez ce
soir avec vos trois collègues Thomas
ménager bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être là
député rassemblement national du Loiret
bonsoir Alexandra martinons bienvenue
député les républicains des Alpes
Maritimes enfin bonsoir Valérie Rabo
bonsoir ravi de vous avoir sur ce
plateau député socialiste du tarnégaron
et vice-présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale inutile de préciser que votre
regard de journalistes et d'observateurs
avisés de ces conférences de presse que
vous connaissez bien Patrice dunabel
nous intéresse ce soir donc vous
intervenez n'hésitez pas quand vous le
voulez on va commencer avec les mots et
la mise en scène du chef de l'État le
bon sang l'ordre l'autorité c'est dans
le recap de Bruno donet tout de
suite bonsoir Bruno bonsoir Miriam
bonsoir à tous bonne année et ravi de
vous accueillir dans cette émission à
nouveau d'ailleurs que vous connaissez
alors vous avez tout regardé
attentivement hier soir et vous avez été
intéressé par un paradoxe oui alors un
paradoxe myiam entre d'un côté le
constat que le Président de la
République a choisi de poser d'entré de
jeu et de l'autre les propositions qu'il
a choisi de formuler alors le con
c'était celui-ci au fond le monde d'hier
est en train de s'effacer bien le hiic
c'est qu'en dépit du fait que le monde
d' soit en train de s'effacer
figurez-vous qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a
jamais cessé de s'y réfugier ça n'a
d'ailleurs pas échappé à nos confrères
du monde et de libération qui l'ont
épinglé ce matin libération l'a trouvé
très vieille France et le monde l'a jugé
par trop conservateur alors pourquoi
qu'avait-il à ce point de nostalgique et
bien il nous a d'abord proposé tout un
cocktail de mesures aux couleurs
délicatement CPIA donct je vous ai
conccté ici un petit
florilège dès la rentrée
2024 l'instruction civique sera refondée
la tenue unique qui a donné lieu à tant
de débats ces derniers mois dans notre
pays sera expérimenté dès cette année
dans une centaine d'établissements notre
France sera aussi plus forte par la
relance de sa natalité natalité uniforme
à l'école marseillaise bienvenue à tous
dans la startup nation
2024 mais alors pourquoi donc le
président de la République a-t-il voulu
à ce point se téléporter dans cette
France là et bien la réponse elle tient
en un tout petit slogan écoutez pour que
la France reste la France un slogan
chipé aux deux Éric ERC Zemour et erriic
siioti qui ont très bien compris que
cette France éternelle et bien elle
séduisait un un très grand nombre
d'électeurs alors vous avez été aussi
piqué au vif je crois par une petite
phrase du président qui vous a pris une
une forme de quoi de défi personnel qui
vous a alors vous connaissez Myriam ma
passion pour les archives politiques et
celles de la télévision et je dois bien
vous l'avouer hein en entendant Emmanuel
Macron prononcer cette petite phrase je
me suis senti un peu apostrophé écoutez
les archives sont là pour le montrer
allez aussi les chercher celle-là aller
chercher les archives qu'il a dit alors
en entendant ça j'ai eu envie de le
prendre au mot j'ai donc épluché toute
ma collègue très personnel d'archive de
conférence de presse présidentielle et
et j'ai trouvé à qui Emmanuel Macron
avait fait autant d'emprunts hier soir
celui qui l'a tant imité c'est lui il
est tout à fait vrai que depuis toujours
et aujourd'hui je me fais en effet de la
France une certaine idée au général de
il a emprunté sa certaine idée de la
France parce qu'être français c'est
d'avoir c'est avant tout avoir des
droits et des devoir c'est porter une
certaine idée de notre nation de son
histoire de son ambition mais il lui a
aussi fauché l'art très rhthorique de la
répétition l'école l'école l'école
Europe l'Europe l'Europe et même celui
de l'ordre indissociable du progrès mais
avoir une France plus forte c'est aussi
assurer l'ordre pour la France il faut
progrès il faut pas la pagaille voilà du
reste même en terme de réalisation j'ai
remarqué que les plans de coupe version
2024 sur la relève Gabriel hatal était
rigoureusement les mêmes que ceux que le
réalisateur de
1965 avait alors proposé lorsqu'il
filmait le jeune Valérie Giscard destin
et puis surtout surtout j'ai découvert
d'où venaient les origines du fameux en
même temps la France c'est tout à la foi
tout à la fois et j'ai même trouvé où
Emmanuel Macron avait dégotté le nom de
son parti un grand peuple en marche
alors voilà Miriam hier soir le
président était à la manœuvre c'est vrai
mais il a beaucoup regardé dans son
rétro où l'on comprend qu'on peut
parfaitement être en marche et en marche
arrière merci beaucoup le défi est
relevé bravo d'avoir ouvert le placard à
archive golienne merci beaucoup Bruno
donet Christopher weisberg pour que la
France reste la France qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire précisément est-ce que la
France est menacée et si oui de quoi de
disparaître de se diluer de quoi
précisément bah c'est évidemment il a
rappé le contexte politique
international qui est un monde il a
parlé de des risques pour la démocratie
moi je suis en Amérique du Nord il y a
un risque de Donald Trump face à un
grand démocrate qui s'appelle Joe Biden
et qui est aussi contesté il y a
plusieurs risques une tentation parmi
beaucoup de peuples d'aller vers des
extrêmes droites et c'est vrai que c'est
une des constatations ce ne serait plus
la France si elle basculait dans les
mains du RN pour vous ah bah évidemment
ça je crois que c'est c'est moi en tout
cas c'est c'est ce que je pense depuis
toujours je pense que c'est ce qu'a
répété le président de la République la
France et vous avez parlé de cette ce
scénario un peu gaulien c'est à la fois
un gouvernement qui est très jeune mais
évidemment le président de la République
déjà le décorum est un décorum qui qui
est très 5e République qui est très gén
mais ce ce slogan il faut quand même
qu'il signifie quelque chose vous parlez
de de la menace Trump pour l'instant ce
sont les Américains euh il le prend
quand même à Eric Zemour ça c'est un
fait 2022 à Laurent voquier 2018 la
droite parle de recyclage est-ce que le
en même temps c'est fini est-ce que vous
mettez le cap à droite désormais non moi
je crois pas parce qu'encore une fois il
a eu aussi des propos sur l'inégalité
des chances les inégalités à la source
donc il a eu aussi un propos sur les
discriminations comment il fallait
lutter contre les discrimination par
l'école par la culture donc il a eu
aussi des propos qui parlent plus au
progressistes mais évidemment il y avait
ce rapport à l'autorité ce rapport à
l'autorité il est en ce moment dans la
société française assez important on le
sait l'autorité des maires l'autorité
des policiers l'autorité de à l'école
c'est quelque chose qui aujourd'hui est
est
contestétiqu politique c'est ce que vous
voulez dire aussi non benah justement
j'espère pas j'espère pas parce que
quand on est républicain on veut on veut
cette autorité et c'est vrai qu'au fond
ça devrait tous nous rassembler c'est
aussi un gage d'unité l'autorité Thomas
ménager quand même le réarmement civique
et même démographique avec le retour des
grands textes fondateurs de la nation
qui seront chaque année parmi les les
cours d'instruction civique les
cérémonies de remise de diplôme
l'uniforme l'apprentissage de la
Marseillaise le contrôle des des écrans
le soutien de natalité le bon sens près
de chez vous on pourrait rajouter ça
sonne d'où à vos oreilles tout ça déjà
répondre à mon collègue si la France
basculait aux mains de Marine Le Pen et
Jordan bardellin en 2027 ça serait la
démocratie ça serait encore la France et
c'est je trouve ça assez méprisant pour
les 13 millions de Français qui votent
pour nous mais pour répondre à votre
question et puis pour revenir sur cette
édito qui était très bien fait c'est pas
parce que vous mettez votre siège au
niveau du général de Gaulle que vous
pouvez être le général de Gaulle et que
le costume est pas un peu trop grand
pour vous et c'est ce que j'ai ressenti
hier soir en écoutant le président de la
République et le général de Gaulle
c'était pas la nostalgie c'était pas
regarder derrière c'était être tourn
vers l'avenir vers le futur c'était le
progrès c'était la justice sociale
c'était l'ordre et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui malheureusement on l' vu
avec les émeut ça a été le désordre on
le voit avec les difficultés que nos
Français rencontrent en matière de
pouvoir d'achat c'est pas il y a pas de
justice sociale les Français souffent de
plus en plus donc c'est pas parce que
vous ESS rien annoncé qui vous
satisfacee aujourd'hui par
exemple service national universel dis
généraliser ça vous le proposez il y a
des choses qui vont dans le bon sens
mais encore c'est les paroles nous
allons voir dans les actes aujourd'hui
il essaie de courir après Jordan
Bardella qui est 10 points devant la
liste de la majorité dans les sondages
en essayant de reprendre un certain
nombre de thématiqu si ça va dans le bon
sens nous le dirons l'uniforme nous
l'avons proposé sa majorité mon collègue
qui est en PHAs de la majorité
Renaissance l'a refusé quand le
rassemblement national l'a mis dans sa
niche parlementaire quand il a choisi
l'ordre du jour donc il y a aussi un
défaut de cohérence au sein de cette
majorité et c'est surtout que les
Français ont été oubliés rien sur le
pouvoir d'achat si ce n'est de dire aux
Français à attendez je vais vous prendre
6,5 milliards 5 milliards sur
l'augmentation de l'électricité les
taxes sur l'électricité on attend
arbitrages définitif sur les on est dans
on est dans ces 1 milliard et demi sur
sur les franes médicales et peut-être
qu'en 2025 après vous avoir déjà promis
en 2023 une baisse de milliards sur les
6,5 milliards je vous en rendrai 2
milliards c'est pas du tout ce qu'il
faut faire et c'est pas ce qu'attend les
Français Valéri abo l'école mais c'est
quand même la mer des bataille c'est ce
qu'a dit Gabriel Atal la
France comment dire vieille France voilà
je cher c'est le titre de libération
est-ce que est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce titre ou est-ce que vous le
trouvez exagéré je suis d'accord avec ce
titre je pense que ce qu'on attend du
président de la République c'est pas de
se retourner vers le passé c'est
d'avancer il dit le monde ancien
disparaît mais pour chaque président de
la République le monde ancien a disparu
et c'est bien là la ce qu'on attend d'un
président de la République c'est de de
tracer un cap vers le futur mais savoir
d'où l'on vient pour savoir d'ù l'on
vient Mo n'ai jamais de problème avec
savoir d'où l' vient on a une histoire
qui est absolument fantastique et qui a
été vraiment une boussole pour de très
nombreux pays vous savez tout à l'heure
on a encore eu avec la présidente Bron
pivé un entretien avec la présidente du
Parlement chipriote elle dit la France
véritablement véhicule des idées des
valeurs humanistes qui nous ont guidé et
qui sont vraiment une boussole pour nous
donc ce sentiment de dépossession voir
de déclassement ce sentim de exagérer il
n'existe pas dans le regard des autres à
l'étranger mais j'observe que le
Président de la République va avoir de
mandats 10 ans qui lui reste 3 ans et
demi c'est-à-dire un dernier tiers il
part comme si il'ait comme s'il arrivit
au pouvoir et qu'il découvrait la
situation ça c'est inacceptable quand il
regrette que certains professeurs soient
pas remplacés il a supprimé 6500 postes
dans l'Éducation nationale depuis 2017
donc on peut pas dire d'un côté l'école
est la priorité et oui elle est la
priorité pour la République et en même
temps supprimer 6500 postes dans
l'Éducation nationale avec toutes les
conséquences qu'on peut connaître
sur donc moi ce que je je j'observe
c'est que les vrais sujets n'ont pas été
traités les vrais sujets n'ont pas été
traités qu'est-ce qu'on en pense à
droite parce que là aussi Alexandra
Martin on retrouve un certain nombre de
vos proposition la tenue unique et
d'autres est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que c'est une forme de de
victoire idéologique ce cette conférence
de presse vous avez commencé l'émission
en posant cette question et si c'était
mieux avant et moi j'ai envie de vous
dire et si c'était mieux à droite cette
droite classique et républicaine qui est
la mienne qui est celle d'ericotti de
David Lisnard et de mon groupe qui a
fait 8 % aux dernières européennes et à
peine et à peine C avec Val je ne suis
pas dans le dénis au contraire
d'Emmanuel Macron néanmoins toutes les
propositions qu'il a pu développer hier
effectivement sur l'uniforme l'unité de
la nation l'ordre ce sont des des des
Prin princip et des valeurs que nous
portons depuis très longtemps moi j'ai
entendu hier un Emmanuel Macron 1 qui
parlait à Emmanuel Macron 2 qui a dit
tout et n'importe quoi effectivement il
a soupoudré effectivement quelques
quelques action qui pourrait plaire à la
droite il a été même jusqu'à voler
effectivement vous en avez parlé le
slogan d'Eric cioti qui était celui de
la primaire de 2021 il a aussi été
emprunté à David
lissnard
voilà lesux de débureaucratisation et
d'excès de normes et il a été même
jusqu'à parodier la
gauche rassemblement national et alr
parce qu'après tout certains ont réussi
Nicolas Sarkozi 2007 il a siphonné les
voix du Ren même pas peur ou il y a
quand même à regarder de près non je
crois pas je pense que les Français
préféront toujours l'original à la copie
sur l'uniforme je vous dis il y a aussi
une cohérence les Français sont pas
idiots ils ont bien vu que il y avait
souvent des belles paroles avec Emmanuel
Macron moi j'étais le premier souvent à
regarder uel Macron à la télévision il
dire il est pas mal ce ce cet homme
politique il a des idées il a quelque
chose il il donne des des faits mais
après dans dans les actes il n'y a rien
il y a souvent que du vent et c'est la
même chose pour le Premier ministre il a
annoncé par exemple on réécoutera après
hein sur le rassemblement national euh
partie de l'appauvrissement collectif et
et venir on sortira les chiffres de la
situation du pays quand il y a
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus de Français
pauvres dans notre pays quand il y a 14
% des Français qui sont en situation de
pauvreté de précarité matérielle qui ont
des difficultés de plus en plus
croissantes dans notre pays donc à un
moment les Français voient bien qu'il y
a un décalage entre un Emmanuel Macron
qui est dans sa tour d'ivoire et la
réalité du terrain et et et et les
sondages le prouvent c'est pour ça que
sa liste est aussi bas et que les
Français le 9 jint françin je pense
auront bien compris que l'Europe peut
changer et que ça sera aussi un message
très claire en vue des élections
présidentielles en placantord voilà on a
compris qu'il y a une bataille
électorale qui est lancée d'une certaine
façon sans sans tête de liste c'est
aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron qui qui va
porter cette bataille c'est une une
forme de lecture de de cette allocution
d'hier soir moi ce que j'ai retenu c'est
que en une phrase c'était le retour de
la politique je pense c'était une
conférence de presse beaucoup plus
politique qu'on l'a dit il y a eu
certain nombre de de mesures qui ont été
annoncé j'ai le sentiment mais c'est à
vous de à vous 4 de le dire de le
confirmer ou de le démentir que il a
pris conscience
peut-être avec un peu de retard
d'ailleurs de la situation arithmétique
parlementaire qui lui manquait 40 voix
pour faire passer des lois relativement
facilement et que donc un certain nombre
de ces mesures allaient être de nature
réglementaire ou des circulaires que ce
soit dans l'éducation l'intérieur et
cetera et que il voulait assister sur la
vie quotidienne des Français alors c'est
la vie quotidienne mais c'est beaucoup
le symbole c'est du symbolique la tenue
la Marseillaise les les rites de passage
avec les les cérémonies de di est-ce que
ça parle au français le symbolique on n
pas de réforme structurante ça parle à
une catégorie de Français je pense que
sur l'uniforme les cérémonies de remise
des diplômes ça parle peut-être plus au
aux grands-parents qu'aux parents ou aux
enfants mais j'insiste moi ce qui ce qui
m'a frappé c'est le côté chef de guerre
du du Président on sait par toute une
série de témoignages moi je l'ai pas
personnellement entendu mais je sais
qu'il le dit qu'il est un peu obsédé à
l'idée de ne pas être le président quiit
fin mai 2007 accueillera sur le perron
de l'Élysée Marine Le Pen alors
justement je pense donc que le le débat
le combat singulier qu'il a engagé hier
avec Marine Le Pen et Jordan Bardella
c'est bien sûr dans la perspective des
européennes pour essayer de réduire le
l'écart qui apparaît dans les intentions
de vote mais déjà déjà dans la dans la
présidentielle et juste pour terminer ce
qui ce qui m'a un peu frappé étonné en
même temps c'est le mélange entre le
gouvernement alors l'image du
gouvernement je sais bien que ça existé
après de Gaulle enfin pour moi c'est
c'est
lesousésouvernement du général de GA les
présidents tous les présid ah bah ce qu'
faisait au RTF c'était la diffusion de
la conférence de presse sur je sais plus
5 ou si chaîne ça c'est sûr mais il y a
ce côté le gouvernement jeune très jeune
même resseré ça c'est un autre sujet
mais et puis des accents beaucoup plus
nostalgiques que il l'a été sauf une
phrase qui moi aussi m'a frappé je sais
pas ce que vous en pensez qui est les
les enfants vivront mieux qui était un
aspect très positif donc il y a il y a
un mélange de de nostalgie et de
confiance malgré le le constat il a
commencé par ça que le monde est en
train de changer et que les nuages
s'accumulent aour alors vous l'avez dit
excellente transition Patrice beaucoup
de contraste he quandme onê à
l'Assemblée nationale et dans ce qu'il a
annoncé hier ben il y a pas beaucoup de
lois le Parlement serait-il tourner voir
court circuité faut-il s'en inquiéter la
réponse de yelbrun Pivet ce matin sur
TF1 il n'y a jamais de contournement de
du Parlement et je ne le laisserai
évidemment pas faire mais ça n'est pas
l'intention du Premier ministre en
revanche vous savez depuis des dizaines
d'années et je le partage nous disons
que nous légiférons trop en France donc
si nous parvenions enfin à légiférer
moins et à légiférer mieux sur les
sujets dont le Parlement serait saisi je
pense et qu'avec moi l' ensemble des
parlementaires seront extrêmement
satisfaits Valérie Rabo moins de lois
pour des lois meilleures est-ce que de
lois pour des lois meilleurs il y a pas
de problème par contre que l'Assemblée
nationale soit contourné c'est ce qu'on
observe parce que je pense que Gabriel
Atal est le seul Premier ministre qui va
prononcer un discours de politique
générale 3 semaines après sa nomination
c'est-à-dire que pour l'instant on ne
sait pas quel est le cap qu'il donne à
son gouvernement et je pense que c'est
une première dans l'histoire de la 5e
République Aland
plus que 3 semaines oui 2 mois 2 mois
alors chabandbas ça fait mieux et
c'était euh il avait été nommé fin juin
début juillet donc c'était peut-être
raisou en tout cas là c'est quand même
pour en tout cas sur les 25 dernières
années c'est une première euh ça c'est
un premier enfin c'est un premier acte
qui qui me paraît important le président
de la République mais c'est quoi c'est
une mauvaise manière ou ça ça vide
complètement reflète effectivement ce
que vous disiez sur le président de la
République prend conscience qu'il lui
manque 41 voix et que Ben et du coup il
va tout faire pour contourner
l'Assemblée nationale à chaque fois
qu'on contourne l'Assemblée nationale on
l'a vu avec la loi immigration on l'a vu
avec d'autres lois de toute façon
l'expression du peuple se fait dans la
rue et c'est pas bon puisque l'Assemblée
nationale doit être le réceptacle de ces
différentes op mais il a essayé il a
essayé malgré tout ce compromis on l'a
vu sur les retraites vous n'étiez pas de
la partie des partenaires avoir essayer
parce que depuis juin 2022 nous savons
et c'est une première sous la 5e
République sauf sous recard où il
manquait qure voix pour lequel il manque
41 voix
l'Assemblée nationale reflète
aujourd'hui la diversité de la société
française et ses fractures s'il y avait
une dissolution demain je ne suis pas
certaine qu'il aurait une majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale or la 5e
République a été construite pour une
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée nationale
vous dites que c'est dangereux cette
méthode bah c'est très dangereux c'est
effectivement très dangereux parce que
de toute façon ça se retrouve pouve
avoir des mouvements gilets jaunes et
autres on voit aussi ce qui se passe
dans d'autres pays européens et je pense
qu'il serait important qu'il puisse y
avoir un vrai débat démocratique ici à
l'Assemblée nationale feisberg al alors
là je suis pas d'accord avec votre
interprétation du délai moi au contraire
hier le président de la République c'est
quand même aussi nos institutions il a
fixé un cap il a fixé des orientation
ensuite le fait que on laisse du temps
au Premier ministre pour aussi aller
négocier d'accord un accord avec la
majorité ça c'est la moindre des choses
mais aussi avec les oppositions parce
que comme vous le dites on est toujours
en majorité relative on sait très bien
que c'est compliqué on a quand même
réussi à avoir pas mal de textes adoptés
hein on parle souvent des 493 mais en
fait c'est uniquement sur les textes
mais la démocratie représentative
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous en faites
qui aussi une par qui est une première
est-ce que vous contournerez le
Parlement par des des décrets des la
voie règlementaire est-ce que c'est la
voie privilégiée aujourd'hui à quoi vont
servir les députés dans les prochains
mois les prochaines années non mais de
toute façon il y aura des textes il a
des textes sur l'énergie qui sont prévus
il y a une loi constitutionnelle il y
aura des réformes institutionnelles qui
sont importantes il y en a jamais eu
hein sous François Holland il y a pas eu
de réformes institutionnelle importante
donc on a eu beaucoup légiféré et c'est
vrai que je je je souscris à ce que dit
elbrun pivé au fond ce qu'on a vu
notamment sur la loi immigration c'est
qu'on arrive avec des textes qui sont
censés avoir des objets politiques
importants et puis qui deviennent
plétoriqu avoir une méthode qui permet
de négocier plutôt un peu mieux avec les
oppositions des accords politiques moi
je trouve ça très bien et en fait je
devrais encourager les LR savent jouer
cette partie- làà puisqu'ils le font
avec un certain talent il faut
l'admettre mais le Parti socialiste
aussi devrait faire apparaître comme
proposant des des choix proposant des
orientations réussir à faire des accords
moi je regrette par exemple que sur un
texte de mon collègue Marc Ferraci sur
les inégalités sur les discriminations
sur le testing et bien il y a pas un
député socialiste alors que c'est un
objectif que vous partagez qui a voté ce
texte vous auriez pu avoir l'honnêteté
de dire que votre loi sur les énergies
renouvelables est passée grâce au voix
des socialistes que nous sommes le seul
groupe à gauche à
la gouvernement cette majorité a trouvé
des alliés fois à gauche parfois à
droite et je crois que le rassemblement
national vote certains texes un certain
nombre de textes notment le texte
immigration même si ça a dérangé G on
avance parce que l'autre grande priorité
elle est sur le terrain économique cette
fois ce sont les classes moyennes
c'était un objectif c'est désormais une
certitude les impôts des classes
moyennes vont baisser de 2 milliards
d'euros et dès l'année prochaine les
classes moyennes là encore un marqueur
de droite
explicationamava
dès sa prise de fonction à Matignon
Gabriel hatal fait des classes moyennes
sa priorité cœur battant de notre pays
artisan de la grandeur et de la force de
notre nation française ces femmes ces
hommes ces familles qui se lèvent tous
les matins pour aller travailler qui
peuple notre territoire et que
l'onentend pas souvent mais qui sont
toujours au rendez-vous de leur
responsabilité les classes moyennes la
nouvelle grande cause du quinena accusé
d'être le président des riches Emmanuel
Macron veut devenir le Président de la
France qui travaille il y a ce que
j'appellerai une France de l'angle mort
c'est tous nos compatriotes qui gagne
déjà trop pour être aidé et pas assez
pour bien vivre c'est la France
populaire la France des classes moyennes
la France qui dit quand vous proposez
quelque chose c'est jamais pour
moi et pourtant c'est celle qui tient le
pays alors le président Macron leur
promet 2 milliards d'euros d'impôt en
moins pour
2025 mais que les classes moyennes le
terme est mal défini mais on considère
que ce sont les Français qui touchent à
peu près entre 1500 et de 1500 € net par
mois l'exécutif au chevet de la France
qui travaille de quoi rappeler la France
qui se lève tôt d'un certain Nicolas
Sarkozi France qui se donne du mal il
faut qu'on encourage absolument le
travail qu'on soutienne les gens qui
travaillent que le fait de travailler de
ne pas travailler c'est pas la même
chose mais ce n'est pas tant dans le
rétroviseur que regarde le gouvernement
mais plutôt sur son extrême droite après
avoir conquis une grande partie des
classes populaires le rassemblement
national lorgne désormais ces Français
touché par la peur du déclassement les
classes moyennes pourraient bien passer
de majorité silencieuse à catégorie
déterminante pour l'élection
présidentielle de
2027 Thomas ménager de milliard d'euros
c'est beaucoup c'est dès le prochain
budget 2025 vous voterez vous voterez
cette baisse d'impôt alors je pense
qu'on aura pas la possibilité de la la
voter puis qu'il y aura un 493
vraisemblablement' un changement de
méthode et une vrai un vrai dialogue
avec toutes les oppositions et pas que
les oppositions qui sont soumises à la
majorité comme comme les républicains
comme on l'a vu par par en début de de
mandature mais nous tout ce qui ira dans
le bon sens tout ce qui permet de rendre
de l'argent au français nous le voterons
mais ce que je vous dis c'est détourner
là encore un paet de é dis c'est bien
sûr mais ce que dire c'est qu' il prend
d'une main et il redonne que la moitié
voire un/art voire un 5è d'une autre
main 6,5 milliards de hausse sur
l'électricité et les franchises et il
donne le sentiment d'être grand seigneur
en rendant 2 milliards il y a eu une
haosse de 86 milliards des recettes fisc
met en parallèle des masses de milliards
c'est pas directement oui mais attendez
ceux qui prennent le médicaments ceux
qui payent l'électricité il y a aussi
les classes moyennes il y a eu surtout
une manne financière énorme pour l'État
86 milliards puisque les prix ont
augmenté donc automatiquement la TVA est
augmenté et donc il y a eu 86 milliards
de plus dans les caisses de l'État il en
rend 2 milliards donc pour vous il y
aura pas comment dire un ressenti direct
en terme de répercussion porte-monnaie
par mois même si on parvient à trouver
ces 2 milliards la question c'est qui
paye comment vous financez on a déjà une
dette abysale 3000 milliards d'euros des
promesses à Bruxelles déjà de réduire de
trouver 12 milliards d'économie où vous
les trouver ces 2 milliards bah vous
l'avez dit de toute façon c'est sûr
d'ailleurs la la logique de l'inflation
fait qu'il a des recettes fiscales en
plus et au fond cette logique des
baisser les impôts c'est un moyen c'est
d'ailleurs constant depuis depuis 6 ans
il y a eu des baisses d'impôts
régulières donc moi je vous entends
souvent dire queon n pas eu d'action
structurante on a réussi NOTAM avoir des
recettes fiscales c'est plutôt une chose
positive pour un état il y a rien de
pire que de se retrouver mais c'est un
casquette à Bery hein Brena le maire ne
sait pas du tout comment il va répondre
à à cette question des des 2 milliards
il y a il y a un vrai sujet notamment
sur sur les finances publiques on est en
train enfin là aussi ce qu'a proposé le
Premier ministre il l'a répété en li de
groupe c'est qu'il veut travailler avec
les parlementaires plutôt en amont pour
réussir justement à avoir des accords
sur le budget là aussi encore une fois
c'est une logique de concertation ça
consiste à essayer de faire des choix
politiques des choix politiques tranchés
et le faire avec les oppositions Valéri
Rabo je je viens à vous dans un instant
vous êtes expert des questions
budgétaires il y a la question des
impôts de production le sur les
entreprises le gouvernement a annoncé
qu'il comp continuerait à les baisser 2
milliards en plus de baisse pour les
classes moyennes est-ce que on peut se
le
permettre mais la vraie question c'est
celle du pouvoir d'achat des Français
qui travaillent qui voi quand ils
prennent leur voiture comme en tarngaron
ils font 17 km par jour ça leur coûte
200 300 € par mois sur un SMIC c'est
intenable c'est franchement c'est ça
veut dire que ça dévalorise le travail
et j'observe aussi que c'est la première
fois dans notre pays que nous avons une
inflation aussi forte sans indexation
des salaires lorsque dans les années il
y avait une inflation très forte il y
avait une indexation des salaires donc
là votre salaire est grignoté par
l'inflation donc vous dites avec
l'inflation il aura aucun effet des
baisse d'impôts bah si vous avez 100 €
de baisse d'impôt et que vous êtes pris
300 ou 400 € d'augmentation qui de
l'électricité qui de vos carburant qui
de votre assurance qui de votre mutuel
qui de vos dépenses courantes sur
l'alimentation qu'est-ce que sincèrement
vous pensez que le compti non donc
aujourd'hui la vraie réflexion c'est que
le travail paye que vous puissiez vivre
de votre travail et ça c'est il faudrait
que le gouvernement lance une vraie
conférence sociale avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux et qu'il puisse y
avoir de véritables mesures sur les
salaires il n'a pas voulu ni augmenter
le SMIC ni même indexer les salaires sur
l'inflation reste sur l'incitation les
super profits alors que la plupart des
pays européens l'ont fait AC son drama
oui n nous sommes effectivement sur un
soupodrage là aussi 2 milliards d'euros
les économistes ont calculé sur le
périmètre que l'on croit être celui
Emmanuel Macron va définir pour la
classe moyenne c'est 15 € d'économie par
ménage alors toutes les économies
évidemment sont bonnes à prendre nous ce
que nous disons à droite et c'est là où
une vraie politique de droite c'est une
politique effectivement qui s'attaque au
pouvoir d'achat c'est ce que nous avons
fait dès le début de cette session
parlementaire d'impô pour la classe
moyenne c'est dans le programme des
républiains également c'est c'est le
programme c'est bien bien évidemment
être de droite c'est être pour la baisse
des impôts ce n'est pas être ce n'est
pas vouloir être les champions du monde
de la pression fiscale c'est s'attaquer
à la dette c'est s'attaquer aux charges
qui pèsent sur les entreprises et sur
les franç c'est vouloir ramener le
salaire brut au au salaire net et et
nous avons nous pu justement au sein du
Parlement lors du texte sur les pouvoirs
d'achat c'est nous sont nous les
républicains qui avons permis de
d'augmenter le nombre d'heures
supplémentaires défiscalisés de faire
une économie de 30 centimes sur le
carburant et et et de nombreuses mesures
que nous estimons devoir pouvoir
profiter à tous les Français bon ben on
va tout droit sur le 493 si cette mesure
arrive dans un budget c'est une évidence
à entendre ces premières réactions il y
a des voies de passage encore possible à
l'Assemblée nationale et si oui sur sur
quel texte à venir pour terminer ben il
y a le texte il y a le texte énergie
encore une fois il va avoir plusieurs
textes énergie vous êtes très
catégorique sur l'augmentation du prix
de l'électricité mais enfin sur dans
quelle mesure sur quel calendrier tout
ça ce sont des choses à négocier et
c'est le travail du Premier ministre
dans les de semaines qui viennent parce
qu'il se laisse le temps justement pour
négocier avec vous et bien on va voilà
regarder ça attentivement les
consultations jusqu'au discours de
politique générale que vous suivrez bien
sûr en direct sur LCP ce sera le 30
janvier prochain merci à vous vous
restez avec moi Patrice duamel dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties prit ns
affranchi ce soir l'uniforme dans le 93
on y revient qu'est-ce que ça peut
changer on verra ça avec le prof
d'histoire en scène Saint- Yanis roder
qui pourra incarner la tête de liste aux
Européennes on l' compris c'est un
casse-tête en macronie ce sera avec
Richard verli et puis dans Bourbon
Express quel est le menu quelle est
l'histoire du jour à l'assemé je
parlerai de ce qu'attendent les députés
du discours de politique générale de
Gabriel Atal après que le président
adressé les grandes lignes de la suite
de son quinquena hier soir merci
beaucoup Stéphanie des pierres mais
d'abord Patrice duamel on va plonger
dans votre livre le chat et le renard
aux éditions de l'Observatoire qui sort
je le disais aujourd'hui en librairie
déjà bravo pour le sens du timing vous
livrez votre regard personnel sous la
houlette de Jean de La Fontaine s'il
vous plaît sur ces couples exécutifs de
la 5e des du duelliste et duettist
parfois regardez c'est dans l'invitation
de Marco Pomier interview juste
après si on vous invite Patrice duamel
c'est parce que votre ouvrage tombe à
pique le chat et le renard un livre pour
décortiquer les relations entre
président et premier ministre qui mieux
que vous Patrice duamel pour analyser
ses tandemes depuis
1958 vous qui les avez presque tous
connus en tant que journaliste politique
ancien directeur général de France
Télévision 26 couples exécutifs pour le
meilleur et pour le pire et je pense que
quand le président se mêle de gouverner
il se plante dans votre livre vous
associez chaque duo à une fable de La
Fontaine le lion s'en allant en guerre
pour de GA les Pompidou entre les deux
hommes des relations complexes point
d'org mais 68 le 29 mai alors que le
pays s'enlisee dans les blocages et les
manifestations violentes le Conseil des
Ministres est annulé à la la dernière
minute le général de Gaulle disparaît à
Badon Badon George Pompidou est seul
sans information ni
instruction le général avait eu une
crise de découragement croyant la partie
perdue il avait choisi le retrait c'est
le général Massu qui a réussi à modifier
la détermination du général si les
événements avaient mal tourné ce jour-là
comment aurais-je pu tenir autre couple
autre ambiance Valérie Giscard destin et
Jacques Chirac entre l'élyisée et
matigon le malentendu est quasi
scène saisissante à l'été 76 à laquelle
vous assistez Patrice duamel à votre
micro le président remet en cause
l'héritage de Georg Pompidou les
commentateurs qui dissertent sur le
sujet de la défense ont oublié que la
défense que j'ai trouvé était une
défense qui était en état de malaise
Jacques Chirac fulmine Pompidou était
son mentor Chirac qui a vécu aussi une
cohabitation glaciale avec François
mitéran avant de l'affronter à la
présidentielle de 88
question je ne suis pas le premier
ministre et vous n'êtes pas le président
de la République nous sommes de
candidats vous me permettrez donc de
vous appeler monsieur vous avez tout à
fait raison Monsieur le Premier Ministre
on retiendra aussi les tension plus
récente entreisabeth borne et Emmanuel
Macron vous n'avez pas voulu de
Catherine vin vous m'avez vendu
Elisabeth borne comme une perle rare et
voil où on en est ce soirce on une
question pour
vous fontaine pour qualifier le couple
Macron à tal réponse vous l'avez trouvé
le berger et le roi alors qui est le
Berg c'est le berger c'est àal et le roi
c'est le Président c'est une femme sur
l'ambition et la jalousie l'ambition
donc l'ambition
c'est non je jaloux c'est plutôt ce dans
le gouvernement qui aurait bien aimé
être berger à la place de de hatal le
plus jeune président ident de la 5è
République a donc choisi le plus jeune
premier ministre de la 5e il a choisi
son double en plus jeune ou pas Emmanuel
Macron alors ça c'est une bonne question
parce que si on prend tous ces tous ces
couples on on est au 26e aujourd'hui
depuis de Gaulle Michel Debray ce qui
fonctionne c'est en général quand le
président et le Premier ministre ne se
ressemble pas trop quand ils sont
complémentaires quand ils sont d'accord
sur la répartition des rôles peut-être
qu'on y viendra mais un énorme sujet
pour le bon fonctionnement de la
République et de la démocratie et du
pouvoir exécutif très important et quand
le Premier ministre n'a pas d'ambition
présidentielle rapide donc il y a
quelques cases qui sont cochées
actuellement il y en a d'autres qui ne
sont pas vraiment vous dites la
complémentarité ça veut dire quoi
concrètement c'est un mot un peu valise
est-ce qu'il faut être différent dans le
caractère différent dans la manière de
de gérer les hommes différent dans un
contrat qu'on a conclu à deux comment
quel quelle est la meilleure des
complémentarités la meilleure des
complémentarités c'est des sont des
personnalités qui ne s'opposent pas
systématiquement bon c'est pas un secret
que Emmanuel Macron ellisabeth borne il
y avait pas vraiment de de d'atomes
crochu mais c'est aussi qu'ils sont
d'accord sur voilà ce que doit faire le
ce que ce don doit s'occuper le
président et et une marge de manœuvre
une autonomie réelle du Premier ministre
quand le président on s'occupe de tout
un le le Premier ministre n'est qu'un
collaborateur avait dit Sarkozi à propos
de Fillon ou on dit un directeur de
cabinet et cetera et le Président il ne
peut pas s'occuper de tout il a son
domaine réservé comme qui avait été
théorisé par le général de Gaulle mais
il peut pas être en permanence sur tous
les sujets a annoncé lui-même on l'a vu
hier soir il y a beaucoup d'annonce
quand même très précise et c'est vrai
qu'on peut se demander ça sera évoqué
tout à l'heure j'ai entendu fait quelle
marche de œvre Atal va va disposer quand
le président se mêle de gouverner il se
plante il est condamné à échouer on l'
entendu Édouard Philippe vous
l'interrogiez pour un documentaire il
n'était plus Premier ministre à l'époque
il vous a demandé d'ailleurs de garder
ses propos pendant un an pendant un an
mais quelle claque pour
Macron c'est c'est c'est
une parliz de complémentarité tout à
l'heure ça prouve que dès le départ
parce que Philippe c'était aussi d'une
certaine manière la théorie de son
mentor entre guillemets Alain Jupé il
distingue présider et gouverner c'est le
grand sujet de la 5e République on prend
toujours comme modèle de Gaulle Pompidou
de Gaulle présidait et il laissait
Pompidou gouverner alors justement on
connaît pour ceux qui regardent la
Chaîne Parlementaire l'article 20 de la
Constitution oui qui n'a jamais été
appliqué quasiment jamais dans la 5e le
présidentés peu au début au début de au
début de de Michel Debray et de George
Pompidou mais est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
Gabriel Atal ou est-ce qu'hier François
Fillon conduisait et déterminait la
politique de la nation non c'était le
président le fait que le Président
préside et le Premier ministre gouverne
ça n'est pas uniquement pour respecter
la pureté de la Constitution c'est
important pour le pays pourquoi c'est si
important parce que matinon c'est la
ruche et prend 50 et on prend 50
décisions par jour à matinon et si sur
ces 50 qui sont de moyenne importance
diverse important le le président veut
annoncer lui-même une dizaine de de de
mesures pas tous les jours mais
régulièrement et et qui se met à la
place du Premier ministre il y a quelque
chose qui fonctionne pas le patron de
l'administration en France c'est le
premier ministre c'est pas le président
de la République et les arbitragees sont
constants plusieurs dizaines
d'arbitrages par jour c'est le pays
entier qui remonte à Matignon adossé à
une une administration plétorique ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas à l'Élysée qui
est un palais assez silencieux et c'est
extraordinaire quand on va à matinon
c'est une ruche et quand on va à
l'Élysée on murmure euh il y a pas
d'éclat de voix ou très peu et c'est
tout à fait étonnant mais ça c'est
quelque chose qui a été théorisé par le
général de Gaulle et qui alors on a tout
a changé le quinquena les réseaux
sociaux les chaînes d'information et
cetera mais c'est pas parce que la vie
politique s'accélère que il faut que le
président s'occupe de tout moi je crois
beaucoup au bon fonctionnement des
institutions de ce point de vue-là avec
des effets sur la vie politique
quotidienne parce qu'il faut que le
premier ministre protège le président
l'avenir dira si Gabriel hatal a des
marches de manœuvre pour
véritablement gouverner faudra-t-il
qu'il se démarque comme un certain
Laurent Fabius qui était qui détenait le
le record du plus jeune premier ministre
il est détrôné l'heure de vérité vous
connaissez l'extrait beaucoup de ceux
qui regardent aussi mais on va le revoir
5 septembre 1984 Laurent Fabius répond à
votre frère Alan duamel est-ce qu'au
fond on peut être un chef de
gouvernement autonome quand on devient
le premier collaborateur de celui dont
on a toujours été le collaborateur
euh je vais vous faire une
révélation lui c'est lui et moi c'est
moi voilà vous le racontez cet épisode
dont on connaît peu les coulisses ce ce
livre c'est pas un livre de de théorie
politique je je c'est un livre je crois
très personnel j'avais envie de raconter
toutes ces histoires parce que j'ai
connu tous ces présidents et ses premier
ministres à l'exception du général de
Gaulle bien entendu et j'avais envie de
raconter ce que j'ai vécu soit comme
report soit comme patron de médiia
euh et cet épisode est très intéressant
parce que Fabius vient va voir miteran
quelques semaines après sa domination il
dit moi je suis très jeune on dit que je
suis votre directeur de cabinet pour que
ça fonctionne bien faudrait que j'ai un
peu d'autorité parce que la marge de
manœuvre ça permet au Premier ministre
d'avoir de l'autorité sur son
gouvernement c'est très important et
ensemble il trouve cette formule
ensemble mitteran et Fabius et Fabius
donc
intervient comme on vient de le voir
dans l'heure de vérité et le rendez-vous
suivant entre miteron et Fabius miteron
lui dit oui j'ai vu c'était pas mal mais
enfin vous avez quand même pris un peu
de distance alors qu'ils avaient trouvé
cette formule ensemble r différ c'est le
chat et le renard le rusé le fourbe
aucun doute il y a un peu de chat il y a
un peu de renard expliquez-nous dans
chacun des coup le le le le chat c'est
la souplesse et la fidélité le renard
c'est la ruse la flatterie la rouie mais
beaucoup de des présidents dont dont je
parle et des premier ministres dont je
parle ils sont à la fois chat et renard
c'est pour ça que cette fable je l'ai
choisi comme titre parce que on voit
dans tous ces épisodes dans toutes les
dans tout ce que je raconte qui sont à
la fois chat et des renards la politique
c'est un bestiaire écrivez-vous c'est
pour ça que vous avez eu l'idée
d'associer les femmes de la Fontaine
d'où vous est venue l'idée pour chaque
couple exécutif en écoutant euh j'ai
écouté un dialogue il y a il y a 2 ans
entre Emmanuel Macron et Fabrice luukid
à l'occasion de l'anniversaire de la
naissance de de Jean de La Fontaine et
c'était j'ai j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant c'était à la fois léger
amusant mais profond et je me suis dit
effectivement ce sont des besestierses
on parle des requins on parle des jeunes
loups et cetera et cetera dans la
politique et quand quand rard miteran
c'est le loup et l'agneau miteran Chirac
c'est le pot de terre et le pot de fer
mitteran crisson euh c'est la perdrille
et lescoques voilà ellisabeth borne et
et Emmanuel Macron c'est la cour du roi
ouais parce que la Cour c'est très
important et c'est souvent la cour qui
gêne le Premier ministre pour favoriser
le président de la République oui la la
question c'est ça finit toujours mal oui
sou souvent franchement le plus souvent
or bah la cabitation ça c'est par
principe même
sie voilà mais ça finit souvent
franchement très mal dans la détestation
dans une forme de de de
jalousie dans une incompréhension et
sont deux postes c'est c'est vous savez
qu'on est la seule grande démocratie où
où ça fonctionne avec un président qui a
autant de pouvoir et un Premier ministre
qui est chargé de mettre en œuvre toutes
les orientations c'est bourré d'anecdote
les 4 minutes les 4 à 5 minutes Michel
Rocard nomé un peu parce qu'il n'avait
pas trop le choix mit Teran l'opinion
l'imposait et parce qu'il voulait le le
l'empêcher de lui succéder racontez-nous
ces 4 minutes et bien rard vient voir
miteran qui lui dit c'est fini vous
allez me remettre votre démission alors
rard essaie de dire mais je voudrais
encore un texte sur les écoutes
téléphoniques il faut que j'aille au
Conseil d'État hab lu c'est complètement
grotesque je vous demande cet après-midi
vous démissionnez ça a duré moins de 5
minutes 4 minutes 30 raconé par Michel
Roca mais la politique est d'une vieux
j'ai fait un livre il y a quelques
années Jacques santamar qui s'appelait
les flingueurs la politique d'une
violence absolument incroyable mais ce
qui m'a intéressé c'est pour ça qu'il y
a toutes ces anecdotes c'est le côté
romanesque mais au bon sens du terme de
de ces de ses présidents de ses premier
ministres et de ses couples oui ça en
dit long sur la chair humaine sur
l'exercice du pouvoir mais aussi sur les
hommes et les femmes parce qu'ell elles
existent désormais matigon allez même si
c'est fini pour Elisabeth B dernière
question très rapidement un destin
présidentiel de Premier ministre c'est
Mornet on peut réussir à devenir
président quand on est premier ministre
c'est difficile Chirac et Beran il on
dans shirac est réussi et George
Pompidou pardon pas miteran qui a pas
été premier ministre mais c'est très
difficile et quand on est alors souvent
en période de cohabitation B la dure
perdu Chirac aussi qu quand il était
premier ministre de de François mitteran
mais c'est difficile parce que il font
campagne sur leur bilan ou Jospin euh
qui est parfois bon comme le bilan de
Jospin pour être il faut se projeter
pour être élu président de la République
c'est très difficile quand on est
premier ministre de devenir président et
ben on attend la suite voilà forcément
il faut l'écrire maintenant avec Gabriel
et puis le la route présidentielle
peut-être pour pour Édouard Philippe le
chat et le renard un livre personnel
vous l'avez compris recommandé
chaudement par LCP président et premier
ministre deux ou trois choses que je
sais deux c'est-à-dire à l'observatoire
vous restez avec moi on va terminer avec
les partis prix de nos affranchi on les
accueille tout de
suite Yanis roder de la fondation
jeanjor
professeur d'histoire géographie en CIN
de l qui va nous donner son regard sur
l'uniforme installez-vous et puis
bienvenue également à Richard verli du
quotidien suisse bli on commence par
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée c'est l'attente qu'est-ce
qu'ils en attendent stéanie les piierre
les députés de ce discours de Gabriel
hatal le 30 janvier et oui ce soir je
vous raconte l'histoire l'histoire d'un
discours encore à inventé celui de
politique générale que va dire Gabriel
hatal que n'a pas déjà dit Emmanuel
Macron hier soir dans sa conférence de
presse pre alors évidemment les députés
de l'opposition ne trépignent pas
d'impatience et pour une fois la France
insoumise leur assemblement national
sont d'accord qu'est-ce que vous
attendez du discours de politique
générale de Gabriel Atal je sais pas on
l'a eu hier non le discours de politique
générale de Gabriel hatal sauf qu'il
s'appelait Emmanuel Macron pas
grand-chose puis que l'essentiel a été
dit hier par Emmanuel Macron qui lui a
coupé l'herbe sous le P j'ai envie dire
de toutes les bonnes nouvelles ou de ce
qui pourrait être des bonnes mesures
symboliques sur l'ordre à l'école même
si cétait culé et la mauvaise nouvelle
c'est-à-dire la hausse des FA
d'électricité effectivement il l'a
laissé pour Monsieur hatal comme
Monsieur hatal devra expliquer comment
ils vont trouver 12 milliards d'économie
alors que cette année ils en ont même
pas trouver deux il y a pas beaucoup de
liberté de ton et d'action pour le
ministre Atal donc pour l'instant il
bénéficie d'une bonne côte de popularité
il s'appuie dessus mais je ne suis pas
sûr que dans le jeu parlementaire ça
change quoi que ce soit j'attends qu'
nous donne un cap mais vraiment un cap
c'est-à-dire quelle mesure concrète
parce que le Président nous a fait un
catalogue hier soir mais on n pas trop
de vision alors comme il n'y aura pas de
vote de de confiance dans la foulée de
ce premier discours de Gabriel hatal
devant les députés bien il y a
évidemment un moins d'enjeu pour
l'opposition même si la gauche a déjà
dit qu'elle déposera une motion de
censure qui n'a aucune chance d'être
adoptée dans le camp présidentiel on
assure quand même que si si si un
discours de politique général ça sert à
quelque chose même après les presque 3h
de prime time du
président discours de politique générale
qui donne un cap comment on emmène les
français pour continuer à réformer le le
pays comment on emmène les Français sur
sur l'école sur sur le logement sur
c'est pas ce qu'a fait le président de
la République hier soir si mais euh
c'est le premier au Premier ministre
maintenant de détailler la feuille de
route on est un peu dans dans deux temps
on est d'un côté les grandes
orientations et de l'autre côté les
mesures techniques pour arriver à ces
grandes orientations donc c'est pas du
tout la même chose évidemment on aura
besoin de ce ce discours de politique
générale alors en fait dans le camp
présidentiel ce n'est pas le discours du
30 janvier qui aiguise les curiosités
mais la composition complète du
gouverneement qui entrera qui n'entrera
pas Gabriel Attal va-t-il rééquilibrer
son équipe qui penche à droite avec des
députés renaissan issu de la gauche le
modem peut-il espérer un second
ministère les couloirs de l'Assemblée
Myriam bruissent de rumeurs les les
prétendants arrosent Matignon de notes
sur leur sujet de prédilection alors en
fait une quinzaine de ministres et
secrétairees d'état devrai s'ajouter aux
14 déjà nommés et selon la toute
nouvelle porte-parole du gouvernement
priscat il faudra patienter encore un
peu environ une dizaine de jours merci
beaucoup Stéphan Patrice du ça vous
choque qu'il ait parlé avant est-ce que
c'est plus qu'une mauvaise manière que
ce que j'ai ce que j'ai trouvé très très
difficile à
gérer pour le Premier ministre c'était
Édouard Philippe parce que le président
de la républiqueour devant le Congrès la
veille la veille s bien
équipous le sujet c'est plus
effectivement ça a été évoqué que
reste-t-il vraiment à dire en dehors de
mini détail peut-être des mesures sur le
pouvoir d'achat quelque chose qui
manquait hier alors je crois que ça
avait été annoncé c'est dont je pense la
France a besoin sur la décentralisation
il y avait il y a rien eu sur la
décentralisation peut-être qu'il y aura
quelque chose là-dessus mais en tout cas
son champ de manœuvre est quand même
relativement limité mais discours
politique général c'est c'est très
difficile parce qu'il faut éviter un
catalogue il y a beaucoup de premier
ministres qui qui ont fait un catalogue
interminable et il faut trouver un style
parce que c'est là que le nouveau
Premier ministre
s'affirme il l'a déjà un peu le style
non gabrielal oui moi je pense que les
trois les trois discours de politique
général les meilleurs je pense ça a été
chabandelmas bien entendu la nouvelle
société ça a été Michel Rocard et ça a
été manuel Vals c'était trois très bons
mais il y en a beaucoup qui ont été
décevants voir médiocre la barre est
haute on verra comment ça se passe donc
le le 30 janvier prochain Yanis je
disais vous êtes professeur on scne
Saint-Denis regard de prof sur cet
éternel débat sur sur l'uniforme à
d'école mais là il va pouvoir trouver
une certaine forme de de concrétude
parce qu'on expériment et si ça marche
on généralise qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez et qu'est-ce qu'en pensent vos
élèves tiens alors oui Miriam j'ai
échangé dernièrement avec eux sur l'idée
du port d'un habit commun à l'école et à
ma grande surprise la majorité de mes
élèves y est favorable et apprécie
l'idée ah oui d'abord parce qu'en fait
ça fait américain hein ils sont abrevés
de séries et de clips venus des états
Unis c'est un peu le rêve américain à
porortter de en gros ça ça les amuse
ceci dit ils ont quand même plein de
questions il y a ceux qui se demandent
si ça va être beau ou ça va être moche
si ce sera le même uniforme partout s'il
y aura le drapeau français dessus et si
les filles porteront des jupe parce que
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt le jein et le
survette voilà puis a qui s'inquiète de
savoir ce qui va payer en fait et un
élève m'a dit Monsieur l'école elle est
gratuite non oui c'est vrai puis il a
ajouté ben elle doit le rester ce qui me
semble une évidence h la tenu unique on
sait pas si c'est un uniforme on verra
vos collègues tiens ils en pensent quoi
alors évidemment mes collègues je les ai
pas tous sondés vous imaginez bien mais
ce que j'entends
beaucoup c'est que ce n'est pas pour eux
un vrai sujet voilà pour eux c'est de
l'affichage vous savez les enseignants
sont aujourd'hui préoccupés préoccupés
par le niveau de leurs élèves préoccupés
par les conditions de travail leur
possibilité d'enseigner dans les
conditions convenables par leur salaire
par le manque d'enseignant mais aussi
par la formation par exemple dont on
annonce qu'elle se ferait sur le temps
de vacances alors le port de l'uniforme
ou de la commun ne peut-être vu que
comme un gadget qui ne réglera rien des
problèmes structurels de l'école et
d'ailleurs la polémique involontairement
déclenché par la nouvelle ministre de
l'éducation nationale montre que ces
sujets bah sont très sensibles et que le
monde enseignant est à fleur de peau h
c'est sûr que c'est pas une tenue qui
qui règle les inégalités sociales ça ça
saurait vous en pensez quoi vous vous
Yanis roder le professeur d'histoire
alors personnellement j'y vois peut-être
un intérêt les études et sondages
montrent qu'une part conséquente de
notre jeunesse a du mal à se penser
comme partie intégrante de la société en
général elle a tendance à réfléchir
d'abord en terme d'intérêt particulier
voire individuel plutôt qu'en teres
d'intérêt général or le port d'un habit
commun a pour première conséquence
visuellement d'intégrer chacun dans un
collectif et l'idée peut plaire à
certains élèves le même habit pour tous
dessine aussi un espace d'égalité
égalité symbolique qui peut à mes yeux
peut-être favorisé le sentiment
d'appartence d'appartenance à la société
miniature que représente un
établissement scolaire et de là bien sûr
participer à la construction citoyenne
et républicaine qui dépasse l'école
Ernest Renan le grand historien et
philosophe disait dans son fameux
discours de 1882 qu'est-ce qu'une nation
l'essence d'une nation est que tous les
individus aient beaucoup de choses en
commun et aussi que tous ai oublié bien
des choses alors peut-être que
l'uniforme à l'école participera de
cette construction citoyenne alors
pourquoi ne pas l'expérimenter mais si
vous me permettez Myriam si Emmanuel
Macron souhaite que le réarmement
civique qu'il appppelle de ses vœux
fonctionne il devra aussi répondre de
mon point de vue à une exigence celle de
la justice sociale et scolaire car on ne
construit pas une nation quand les
populations vivent dans des mondes trop
trop éloignés pardon voir séparer oui ça
ne peut pas suffire à vous à vous
entendre c'est un vieux débat hein c'est
un vieux débat là l'uniforme la tenue
unique vous pensez qu'on pourrait y
arriver quand j'étais au l'école
communale et au collège on a porté les
blouses moi je trouvais ça bon avait pas
de folie mais ça ne me dérangeait pas du
tout et effectivement quand même c'est
on on est totalement dans le symbole
alors effectivement c'est pas l'Essen
Mar profite quand même Patrice duamel
puisque Yanis roder en parlait Amélie
oud Castera en pleine tourmente qui a
reçu le soutien appuyé du du président
de la République hier qui reconnaît
quand même une maladresse vous ne faites
pas mystère que vous êtes de de sa
famille puisque vous êtesè son oncle
qu'est-ce que vous vous pensez de de
cette entrée fracassante rut Grenel bah
je pense qu'elle a été elle l'a reconnu
elle-même et le président l'a dit hier
elle a commis une
maladresse peut-être aurait-elle
pu rectifier plus vite mais bon c'est
difficile d'arriver comme ça dans un
dans un milieu politique
les voilà quand on a déjà tous les synd
P je pense ça va dépendre de des des
premier contact réel de vra discussion
négociation concertation avec les
organisations syndicales mais le le le
Président je pense a trouvé un bon
argument hier en se mettant en cause
lui-même on se souvient ce qu'il
s'identifiant d'une certaine façon pour
les ouvrières de de gaz avec ces ces
mots qui ont choqué sur les les îles et
trait qu'il a qu'il a rappelé on va
terminer avec vous Richard verli cap sur
les européennes la bataille est elle est
bien lancée logique la liste de Jordane
Bardella devance celle du camp
macronisttin de plus de 10 points dans
les sondages euh il y a des idées hein
on les a entendu reste à trouver une
tête de liste et ça c'estit le le C tête
et oui qui a aujourd'hui la notoriété le
charisme les arguments et la capacité de
mobilisation pour s'opposer au
rassemblement national et incarner ce
souverainisme européen qu'Emmanuel
Macron a encore défendu hier et bien
pour l'heure le candidat idéal de la
majorité présidentielle il ne vient pas
spontanément à l'esprit c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire alors et pour cause en
2019 c'est le président lui-même qui
avait fait campagne la tête de Liss
c'était l'eurodéputé Nathalie Loiseau
qui était ministre sortant des affaires
européenne Emmanuel Macron sétait
investi et ça avait marché il avait
recollé au score résultat 23 élus pour
Renaissance la majorité présidentiel et
pour le rassemblement national 23,3 %
des voix pour le RN et 22,4 % pour
Renaissance alors 5 ans plus tard bis
repétita l'Europe c'est d'abord
l'affaire d'Emmanuel Macron l'actuelle
ministre Laurence boun elle n'existe que
pour les cercle d'initier d'ailleurs
vous aurez remarqué qu'elle n'a pas
encore été renommée l'eurodéputé
Stéphane séjourné qui qui dirigeait le
groupe Renaissance au Parlement européen
le voilà promu ministre des Affaires
étrangères il va beaucoup s'occuper
d'Europe mais il ne sera donc pas t de
tête de liste qu'est-ce qu'il reste
comme nom le premier qui vient à
l'esprit c'est celui de l'actuel
commissaire européen au Marché intérieur
Thierry Breton qui a l'air d'y penser
clairement il a l'air d'y penser mais il
n'en parle pas et c'est pas si simple
pour lui parce qu'il a été nommé à
Bruxelles après le reget rappelez-vous
de la candidature de sylvie Goulard il
avait été rejeté par le Parlement de
Strasbourg c'est vrai qu'il a tous les
atouts il a pour lui le bilan des
vaccins covid il est l'homme de
l'industrie de défense il connaît tous
les PDG de la planète ou presque mais
retourner aux urnes ça pourrait toujours
lui réserver une mauvaise surprise et
manifestement en croire les bruit de
couloir à l'Élysée c'est pas forcément
le choix du du président qui alors alors
il y a un candidat qui pourrait émerger
quand même il vient de fâcher le
président en exprimant son désaccord sur
le texte immigration mais il est
crédible il est médiatique il est
expérimenté c'est le ministre sortant
des transports Clément Ba qui fut aussi
conseiller Europe et ministre on
pourrait imaginer pourquoi pas que
sylvie Goulard rappelons-le qui a été
blanchi des accusations dans l'affaire
des assistants parlementaires du MoDem
et bien qu'elle repique au truc
puisqu'elle a été elle-même eurodéputée
et à l'époque elle avait plutôt une
bonne image il y a l'italien Sandro gozi
qui est tout à fait charismatique qui
pourrait monter en gamme et puis il y a
la rumeur sur l'arrivée possible à la
tête de la liste d'Olivier verérrand
porte-parole sortant du gouvernement
très proche de Gabriel hatal reste donc
à trancher avec une assurance je pense
que vous n'en doutez pas myiam quel
qu'il soit le candidat sera amené à
s'effacer devant le vrai chef de fil
pour les européennes allez quel nom
Emmanuel Macron bravo et j'ai bien
compris merci merci beaucoup on s'arrête
là pas le temps de vous faire réagir
d'un mot alors oui je pense que ça va se
jouer il y aura je pense qu'il y aura en
avril quelque chose comme ça ou en mai
début mai un face- àface télévisé entre
hatal etord Bardella et Bardella et que
ça se jouera beaucoup là-dessus mais que
ça sera un
vrai pour le Premier ministre merci
beaucoup merci Patrice Dumel merci les
affranchis le chat et le renard
c'est-à-dire aux éditions de
l'Observatoire très belle soirée sur LCP
bien sûr soirée documentaire Jean-Pierre
Gratien à
[Musique]
demain